[Music]
come get a salami brew live here it says
Emmet says I want to salami what the
hell yes in here mommy bro okay I get
salami
there's no salami it's on the ground
like we in the grass you know no I don't
have wine good maybe it's poopoo here we
go rolling in
part two because my corruption file yeah
another day hate living with these
youtubers YouTube a few boomers I missed
the old PewDiePie jacksepticeye no there
you go there you go okay I'm awake I'm
awake would you like to see my fish yes
oh wow how's he doing
not so good I'm killing everybody sorry
my birthday now don't ruin a party my
birthday happy birthday to me oh you can
hear by eating out him so I don't know
they don't walk towards Janna or I'll
smack you
stop hitting me god damn a oh look at
fishy no don't make any trouble okay
we're gonna cause that pocalypse number
15 no another extinction event we've got
to cause trouble and beat people up and
the kick is out I feel like I'm doing
that either party yeah come here
that's the first time you can smack to
the face either what do you mean in real
fish I thought sir
yeah cos can pee yeah
you drink stuff and then you compete
make a full person roll out I'll get in
you look at max that's me I'm not an axe
our brethren
I'm not reach on it alright hey cam
[Laughter]
gotta look for it good today
stop it stop god damn it yeah Felix is
there something wrong in my neck
no you're fine it's a flesh wound
oh good yeah you broke some dirt on it
I'll be fine
dude we can do a trick here okay epic
trip okay let's see record so I imagine
retirement being like just like this oh
[Music]
I'm fine dude I'm fine now nice-lookin
do we play this just like this sumit are
your friends oh jeez I can still do it I
can still do my in the rain jury all
right we got the gun we got the gun we
put you out your misery old man no I
want to live you just you're being
propelled by your blood pressure right
now I'm fine I'm fine
fart back let's go I can't grab it you
grab it I can't have it either you can't
what ooh the fart pack all right here we
go okay underwhelming here I don't know
are you okay oh no do it give it to me
give me a butt I need a butt Wow whoa
whoa just hurt you how does this work I
found them finally here we go ten out of
ten
[Laughter]
I want to like continuously Burt is yeah
I want to go to see Emmet go to space
show Elon how it's done yeah boys you
better respect respect the drift oh yeah
boy faking faking grab Jack well let's
get out of here let me get that giant
Club from before oh there it is oh my
god yeah it's right here yeah it was up
there I'm gonna I'm gonna no no kill a
Boomer today Jesus dance dance
no okay all right we even Raven okay
come on you can do it mate right oh I
want to go there oh yeah I made it all
the way to the top baby all the way hit
that
what's a heavy mm-hmm no like on me like
oh it never I want that thing did you
pull out oh please sorry don't need it
don't need it I'm like a dog that wipes
her ass
hello grandson how are you doing what's
his name thank me Brad all the bodies
are latex I've become what I wanted
always drank all the milk in the store
cuz I'm just trying to pee
but I can't it's stuck part of being old
I guess remember my wife Lucille used to
speaking of prostates
[Laughter]
oh damn it alright find my leg we're
good how are you doing Ken what are you
finally Oh what is this come here
watch this you see that you see this
fish yeah do that I want to do I drink
some coffee on the desk a drink it damn
it
these cokes of you it's a GPL flavor yes
ok I come where's the G fuel right here
that's medicine
I'm coming boys just gonna drink my
pretty pack can whoa oh my god I
exploded ah what is that baby yeah okay
perfect that's the thing there yeah yeah
here's your roar jack drink this damage
can enjoy a new flavor it's good for you
what our labor let's drink the kool-aid
come on boys
change game as boys boys oh you die damn
it I thought you can run around some fat
torso I did god damn boy all right this
is the real game play I got Maddy's god
damned
0:01 die oh I have an idea the fart pack
gives you an extra jump so if you use
that on the gravity you thinking what
I'm thinking what the challenge it works
no I have a mighty hammer
Jesus Christ Jesus the mighty door
mighty door come here the bush me a
boost
I'm flying help sis not again not again
I live here now just in the air my own
business you want it you want it take it
it kills people just by being near them
wait what if I put a balloon on you as
you go up the thing
oh now you're thinking big brain oh I
can grab it yep thank you
yeah it's in my head yeah Oh perfect I
made it I made it
nice thanks bro let me just climb up
here dammit
I made a boy stay mr. Vieau good up here
alright so if I jump from here we should
unlock it then oh I hit something on the
edge god damn it yeah if you get the two
fire extinguishers you go pretty high oh
there's two here is that what you meant
for fire extinguishers yeah got them we
probably could have just done that to
get up this entire time yeah whoa the
world from here there's a trampoline up
there oh you hit the ceiling ceiling
ceiling game okay they drop straight
down okay I'm at the trampoline boys
fairness just call me fall master boys
Oh master 1600 you don't see me but here
I yeah yeah oh god damn it
what's a melon oh it's this thing Oh
chi-su I think you do
we spawn too many things yeah GG GG boys
GTA 6 check it out guys
[Music]